la catastrophe est survenue ici le 2
janvier 2010 9 rue de trévise dans le
neuvième arrondissement de paris une
explosion sous une boulangerie à semer
le chaos et soufflé des immeubles le
bilan humain est très lourd quatre morts
dont deux pompiers et 66 blessés 300
sinistrés ont dû être relogés en ce
moment il ya les commémorations du
troisième anniversaire les
investigations ont permis de déterminer
l'origine du sinistre la rupture d'une
canalisation de gaz un ouvrage municipal
le responsable de la catastrophe sont
désignés par les magistrats
la ville de paris et le syndic de
copropriété de l'immeuble la compagnie
immobilière sipa ils ont été mis en
examen en septembre 2020 notamment pour
homicides et blessures involontaires
en cause les pressions exercées sur la
conduite de gaz par le trottoir de la
rue de trévise qui s'affaissait cela a
causé la rupture du tube et la fuite de
gaz pourtant de nombreuses réflexions de
ce trottoir avaient été effectués depuis
2014 le dossier pointe la mauvaise
gestion de la voirie du service de
l'inspection des eaux et des
canalisations
le manque de suivi le manque de
coordination de relever fiable la
déperdition d'informations la ville
réfute pour le moment sa responsabilité
le syndic de copropriété n'a pour sa
part pas réalisé à l'époque les travaux
qu'ils devaient faire trois ans plus
tard toutes les victimes de cette
effroyable explosions n'ont été que
partiellement indemnisés alors que
d'autres catastrophes du même type avait
rapidement trouver une issue certaines
victimes sont toujours dans un état
grave tel inès une jeune fille très
grièvement blessé durant l'explosion les
jambes atrocement mutilé elle a subi 42
opérations sa vie est devenue un
véritable enfer à l'interpeller mantois
la maire de paris sur son compte twitter
car elle doit financer ses soins mais le
dossier d'indemnisation n'est toujours
pas bouclé mais j'ai plus de temps à
faire des victimes sont fatigués en a
qui sont à l'hôpital on n'en peut plus
vraiment et pour des personnes qui nous
critiquent en faisant ses films histoire
d'argent encore une fois on est à
l'hôpital et des opérations qu'on paye
ou si vous pouvez les payer c'est que
mais si vous laissez nous battre parce
que c'est ce qu'on vous demande de toute
façon la mairie de paris était jusqu'ici
accusé de jouer la montre de privilégier
les procédures les plus lentes son
argument elle n'aurait pas le droit de
verser des provisions tant que les
fondements juridiques de la
responsabilité sans faute n'ont pas été
étudiées et réunion épuisante pour les
victimes se sont enchaînées sans que
rien n'avance anne hidalgo vient
d'accepter de signer un accord de
principe validant l'accord cadre
d'indemnisation la ville provisionnera
20 millions d'euros sans attendre le
terme de la procédure pénale une somme
qui ne présume toutefois pas de la
culpabilité de la ville le syndic de
copropriété sera également mis à
contribution ainsi que le fournisseur de
gaz grdf mais les montants n'ont pas été
communiqués lors de l'hommage certaines
personnes sont venues avec des stylos
pour rappeler à mme hidalgo qu'elle
n'avait toujours pas signé l'accord
certaines personnes ont même eu et la
maire de paris un soutien des victimes
nous explique qu'il ya eu un semblant de
demande de signature s'est toujours pas
signée par contre lundi à une conseil de
paris extraordinaire qui va parler du
sujet donc on espère donc c'est pour ça
qu'on est là avec des stylos pour que ça
soit signé une fois pour toutes
certaines victimes ne sont toujours pas
indemnisés ne sont pas pris en charge
donc de tous leurs frais sont à leur
charge donc voilà aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe c'est que les gens ça fait trois
ans que ça te prenne et que ils sont
souffrance alors que s'achèvent les
hommages du troisième anniversaire de
l'explosion de combien auraient besoin
les victimes pourraient être indemnisées
pour leurs préjudices corporels mais
aussi mobilier de 200 millions d'euros
le procès quant à lui pour aller dans
plusieurs années